welcome back to the games but III stage
brought to you by airheads bites joining
myself and Scott this today on the couch
mess my words up a little bit there but
we've got John from Epic Games here to
talk about paragon welcome thank you
what are you guys showing off the c3 um
well for this we're making a few
announcements and one of the things
we're excited to show off is our
upcoming character so it's a new hero
chimera and he's sort of a male a
brawler and he's built I think it's our
hero team kind of hitting their stride
built specifically to get into team
fights and then stick there so he's
probably gonna change up a lot of the
team comps and the way people are going
through and engaging when they're ready
to brawl so thinking of epics history
the studio obviously you had like unreal
tournament and gaze of war when you were
kind of deciding to create a new game
why did you choose a MOBA well for us we
had a really rare opportunity to build
pretty much anything we wanted the only
constraint on the project from the start
was it's going to be a competitive
multiplayer game so with that in mind we
had the dev team and half the guys we're
familiar with MOBAs the other half not
so much but we were driven by what are
the things that make things sticky and
keep you coming back for us it was the
stories and the stories and stuff with
us the longest four ones of kind of a
shared experience where you have to work
together to achieve something and
mobizen unique way people survive longer
so when you pull off the big play you
have to work together so with that in
mind we went out and we started trying
to take the best elements of MOBAs and
then put a unique spin on it related to
what we've done for a long time an epic
so taking the action you expect from a
game like unreal tournament game like
gears take some of the beautiful high
fidelity graphics that you expect from
the our team did those games and bring
you into the mobile space and so that
was what inspired us we have a kind of a
little bit wary mobile if busily
anything that's not like dota or league
it's it's typically seen as like a very
volatile space and a lot of new players
kind of rise up so i'm thinking like
guardians of middle-earth or infinite
crisis maybe they just because they're
both warner brothers but they both kind
of tried it and it didn't take what's so
different about paragon have you found
like your own community because it is
it's different it's not the isometric
view it's the third person yeah
absolutely for us we're in early access
and so we have been
seeing our community grow and a big part
of what we think makes it unique is that
feeling of action where for most of the
top down Lobos you're you're clicking
and moving your guy along the field but
with our game you're sort of you're
there you're controlling your characters
and verticality is a huge part of what
we think makes the game unique where
you're aiming in full three dimensions
so you have these moments where we've
got a character called rampage pulls
boulders out of the ground and can toss
them at you and as a player you have all
these choices that are directly related
to being in a 3d space do you dash
forward and try and run under it do dash
to the side you can try and have another
teammate throw in one of their abilities
to block it those are the types of
things that we think are unique stories
and plays that come out of Paragon so I
mean I've been reading up about the game
and it seems that you guys are kind of
introducing new patches and stuff all
the time because you are an early access
and you're kind of finding the perfect
balance what's it like how do you play a
bass respond when you introduce a new
patch so frequently and you know they've
been building up their own meta game and
you kind of like throw it on his side a
little bit well it was because of that
really important for us from the very
beginning to say the most consistent
thing about paragon is going to be
change yeah we're going to be growing
and taking advantage of being a live
game which is something that the dev
team was really excited about being able
to continually grow and change the game
so it's been tough but we've been doing
patches and updates every week so we
keep that cadence of change I mean the
most recent that you guys neft was it
ranges and movement speed changed a lot
we made a bunch of changes to those
things in fact this week we've launched
probably our biggest batch of meta game
changes but it's something where we have
a community team telling people I have
these changes are coming we try and
explain why and so the reaction has been
pretty positive where people have
information they understand the goals
we're trying to achieve and our
commitment to changing it to make a
better game so change is always tough
you get used to playing something a
certain way and then uh doesn't quite
work but then there are all of these new
toys and strategies that come along with
it so so far it's been really healthy
but for more casual player maybe that's
not it's more difficult for them because
things change they'll play maybe one day
and then they'll come back next week and
it's it's completely different how are
you guys kind of ensuring that there's
some baseline you know how are you
working to find that baseline before you
make all the other little tweaks and
changes around it for a lot of that it's
the timing of major changes so for
example this week's build we pull
together a lot of these things we've
been working on
for time so there's not that
randomization of every week the game is
completely different yeah another part
of it is iterating on matchmaking so we
group players of equivalent skill
together as best we can so that helps
new players as they on board and over
time from the beginning of early access
to now a lot of our new features and a
lot of our focus has been on making it
more accessible easing onboarding
fighting more tips and hints that type
of thing to make it a better experience
for new players nope it's got some
little 20 French music I'm not know
whether we're not uh so given that this
game is curly an early access and you
are sort of iterating on it and trying
to you know find the perfect balance for
everything is there ever going to come a
point when the game is done you're like
aha Paragon is released and you know
doesn't mean that it won't continue to
update it but you know at what point
will Paragon be like a finished product
what will that take I think part of the
appeal for us of the MOBA genre is that
it's always growing evolving rolling out
new characters seeing the metagame sort
of change as those new characters come
out so for us there's not really an
endpoint inside it's not something we
really fixate on I think for most
developers there's always that thing
they want to change that either
something that didn't come out quite
perfectly or something new they wanted
to try so for us that's sort of what we
look forward to that that constant
change so there's not really something
we think of this up that's it it's done
it's going to be all right what next
what's the next challenge we should
tackle the next change we should roll
out that we think people will enjoy so
it's a free-to-play game how have you
kind of tweaked and worked your
free-to-play model obviously you have
games that are already existing in the
space were they used as like an
inspiration for how much you can charge
for things or was it more you know we
think this is what our community's gonna
want this is what we can charge for all
that so right now we're in paid early
access and we're now just this week that
we're going into free open beta on PC
and PlayStation 4 on August 16 as far as
being fundamentally something that's
going to be free a big part of it was
inspired by something that's sort of wit
epic up over the past few years which is
the changes that we made to the engine
and trying to really focus on what's
best for the player so for us we want to
embrace the model where all the heroes
are free and have been since the
beginning of early access who wanted to
be things that affect gameplay should be
free and we think that's what gives
players the best experience so the stuff
that they opted into if
want to buy something will be cosmetics
things that they decide they enjoy but
it's not mandatory fun to even have a
chance of conjoined that's like it's
like Team Fortress hats right more along
those lines yeah that's something to
compare it to people do love hats a
really i've discovered is there any any
scope to kind of get cosmetic items from
other epic franchises and is kind of
nice little easter eggs or if you guys
plan that out already are they going to
be touches like two other product at
some of the stuff that we talked about
internally and we have a lot of
different things going and so that's
part of the advantage of having a studio
that has a flexible engine and a bunch
of different projects all within the
same space so in our headquarters we can
get inspired by each other so that's
something that we are definitely talking
about thinking of could we get Marcus
penis at Phoenix as a hero I mean come
on mmm that'd be pretty cool can't make
any promises there all right well you
think about it how do you come up with
or decide when it's time to introduce
your new hero is this something you're
constantly iterating on are you
constantly trying to come up with
characters to add or is it like I would
feel like the rosters got a little stale
time to come up with something new well
for us we're releasing new heroes every
three weeks and we're committed to doing
that for the indefinite future for where
heroes come from we've got our design
team and a studio full of really passion
and game players and game developers so
there's a kind of massive pile of
people's ideas where they've got ideas
for heroes that is for kits they come
from batches of concepts for cool things
you might be able to play and they also
come from people who are drawing great
art and some characters that's where
they start just a cool image someone
thinks I can make an awesome hero kit
for that are there any heroes whose sort
of natural gameplay wouldn't really work
I mean have there been ideas where
you're like this seems like a cool
character but it's just not right for
Paragon I think over time especially the
beginning of the project we're defining
what Paragon was going to be we went
through a lot of iterations of heroes
where as we're trying to sort of find
out what the core of the game was we
built certain things where it was ah
this isn't quite working out some of our
older characters the ones in our first
batch that we shipped with at the very
beginning of early access there was some
of they've come so far from where they
started their been bits of that over the
lifetime of the project gotcha so you
mentioned the new characters introduced
every new heroes introduced every three
weeks so how far in advance do you need
to be planning that hero because I majan
even for animation for
graphics for everything to balance yeah
for balance especially yeah that is a
big part of our pipeline and across all
of our teams exactly what you mentioned
animation audio all those different
departments need to line up so we're
generally months ahead as far as what
heroes are currently in developed in
development under being prototype play
tested so that sort of pipeline is
always in motion and we're sort of
shuffle things around at the end as they
come together is there any any scope for
maybe a character that remember your
community has created to be put into the
game mmm that would be quite cool well
you know it's I would say you never know
what the future might hold and it's
something that ideas have come from all
sorts of places within the company and I
think it'd be possible at some point in
the future we don't have any definite
plans for it but it's that type of back
and forth that we think is a great way
of interacting with the community would
you ever consider cycling any heroes out
I mean is there ever going to come a
point where the roster is just
overwhelmingly large and you need to
maybe make some cuts or is the plan just
that like let it continue to grow I'd
say this point the plan is to let it
continue to grow a lot of the moments
that are out there have 100-plus heroes
and so we have a long road ahead of us
of building new characters and I think
speaking for the hardcore mobile players
at epic that's a big part of the appeal
of the game as every hero you've got
offers you a new way of interacting not
just with the game itself but with your
teammates so having that why draw
everything is a big part of the appeal
typically in team-based especially in
mobile you you kind of need a wide
variety of heroes in your kind of team
to make sure that you you can hit the
enemy in very specific ways you know you
need a ranger you need like a healer you
need support all that kind of thing is
there a way to play the game is it open
enough that you can play it like all
brute force so you all support or
something or is there ways that you can
like make sure that each team is
balanced in that kind of way well
something that influenced the very
beginning of the project one of our
goals and along the way we keep
iterating on this is trying to create a
game that allows for a lot of different
types of play that was also part of the
original appeal of doing a mobo rather
than just a straight-up shooter so you
can have success as someone who's
focused on on brawling on melee on range
combat but you can also have a support
character be really valuable healer you
can have characters who are focused on
the sort of the in-game economy of
collecting resources to buff up the rest
of the ten
another big piece of it is using the
card system and allowing that to sort of
bend the way where you and I might play
the same character but we have entirely
different decks you might play more of a
tanky character and I might bend my
character be more of a glass cannon so
that's part of what we think makes it a
little bit more engaging and it allows
people to play in different ways where
it's not just all about killing give it
the earth so many heroes and you do have
the cart system I mean this is a problem
that every mobile phases but how the
hell do you balance those many elements
how do you ensure that as you introduce
new things the game remains consistently
fair well that is a big part of why we
worked so hard to get into a position
where you could do weekly updates so a
big part of it is we play tested within
our team we have a competitive Q a group
that's always taking a look and keeping
their finger on the pulse of balance
we're looking the feedback from the
community we're looking at the metrics
that come out of the game when rates
loss is that type of thing and we have a
lot of people who use time is dedicated
to figuring out okay what do we need to
change what can we safely do within a
week what's going to take longer what
are more sweeping changes so a big part
of it is taking advantage of being alive
and being able to do updates on a
regular basis do you judge people this
video based on who they pick who's the
primary hero is no no they're all our
beloved children oh of course yeah no
it's not like silently like oh he's that
kind of guy yeah so how does how does
the cod system actually work once you're
in game so once you're in game over the
course of a match there will be various
things that you can do that build up
card points and as you level up the
number of card points you have you
unlock the ability to play cards to use
them all the different cards you have
have different values so you can build
decks that can potentially bend towards
having a perfectly balanced deck
beginning middle weight you might build
the deck that is entirely weighted
towards having high-end expensive card
points that you only play at the end of
the match or mid-match when you built up
enough card points so you can strategize
in a bunch of different ways and because
you're in it as a team and some of the
core points that you gather will be
shared across the team it's something
where you can have individual
contribution but as a support character
for example you could be pretty focused
on gathering card points for the team
where you might not be out there and
every team fight but the stuff that
you're doing enables the rest of your
team to activate their cards and change
the way they play the game and power up
so when you're taking on board like if
you're unfamiliar maybe with MOBAs and
you're balancing this card system how do
you manage to introduce that to a new
player that's a big part of what we've
been working on over the past few months
we knew going into early access it was
going to be a pretty hardcore experience
I mean not just because it's a MOBA
because we do have some elements that
are a bit of a break from mobile
tradition including the card system so
that's a big piece of it and right now
we're working towards doing a lot to
ease the onboarding process and educate
people for how those different elements
work so before we wrap up I just wanted
to ask you've already touched on quite a
few of these things but looking out to
the future three months six months a
year from now what changes can players
expect beyond new heroes for us we've
gone a lot plan for continuing to evolve
the metagame we're going to be removing
travel mode eventually and replacing it
with new movement mechanics like
teleport beyond that we're also focusing
on new ways of balancing competitive
play and getting into it in different
ways just this week we rolled out draft
mode matchmaking where the game really
begins when you're building up your team
and making decisions based on who picks
what in the very very initial phase of
matchmaking so between that and seeing
how ranked play will evolve as we design
it within the studio those are the types
of things that people have to look
forward to over the next few months and
when so it's in early access at the
moment yep got a basic coming in August
yeah open beta but free open beta will
be August 16 awesome John thank you so
much for joining us guys for more of
your III coverage from this year's show
make sure you stay tuned of course to
gamespot com you're watching the game
spot stage brought to you by airheads
bites
you